[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
zierke cigarette dans mon coeur tu as
fait un tabac je suis en quête du
bonheur
peut-être qu'il est dans ses draps tia
piraté mon âme a alors que je surfer sur
la vague et j'ai tout raté je rame
alors que tu avais dans ma madrague
francs lesté par ses hôtes et si jolie
tu me rend dingue je rêve du versement
d'actions que toutes les nuits au passé
la bringue à bacau à tribord
on ne partira pas la connerie je veux tu
es cormont suis hors-jeu 4-1 sur l'autre
[Musique]
rive
je sais
[Musique]
même à voir
cette réunion
certaines
pour donner
poison d'avril ou de ses pieds ta mer à
boire n'étudie pas d'un fil je rendrai
amoureux sur miroir l'océan nous importe
mais chez pas cité au groupe que lorsque
l'on passe ma porte même si ces lacs est
assez marrant vient de mon équipage
ratera pour moi sur la jetée
on fera sûrement naufrage mes honnorat
pour moi essayer donc si aujourd'hui je
pense que là vous écrire la partition
ces gens
je vois bien que tu paies t'encule
écurie poste
le ca
[Musique]
cette réunion
je tirais merde vous de venir
cb
la partie suivante
[Musique]
les oignons
m
[Musique]
d'un futur des mouvements ne s'agit pas
d'un film sur les amoureux sont ni roi
[Applaudissements]